I miss the five bakers who've gone.
I'm glad we had a hug before they left.
It's important in life
to conclude things properly.
Only then can you let go.
Don't you agree, Noel?
I can't talk. I'm a tiger.
What are you two doing?
-Er, we're re-enacting the Life of Pi.
-What?
It's pastry week. Life of Pie.
[Sandi] This week...
-Whoa!
-...roll on pastry.
[Kate] I've just ruined
John Lennon's eyes.
With stunning shortcrust signatures...
I think it's a bit of a triumph.
A technical tart...
We've gone the wrong way.
That's so jarring.
And a super-sized showstopper.
It's an amazing construction.
That leaves the bakers...
-You can't serve up a wonky pie.
-...on the verge of collapse.
Don't tell 'em I did that.
[heavy thud]
I'm having a bit of a problem.
[laughter]
I've just realised, actually,
there's only two guys left.
Mmm, I don't mind.
Gotta represent.
[Yan] I've been looking forward
to pastry week for ages
and now it's here,
I'm a little bit anxious.
Pastry can smell fear, 100 per cent.
Morning, bakers,
welcome to pasty week.
-No, it's pastry week. Yeah.
-Is it?
I was looking forward to pasty week,
being a goth and all that.
[Sandi] Yeah, anyway,
for your Signature Challenge,
Paul and Prue,
would like you to make savoury pies.
Now, the flavour
of the filling is entirely up to you.
[Noel] You have to make four pies,
and the judges would love
to see how you fashion shortcrust.
They have to be beautifully decorated.
Think designer pies,
the Coco Chanel of shortcrust.
So, you've got two and a half hours
to make your four gorgeous pies.
-On your marks.
-Get set.
Bake.
Right, let's get cracking.
Cutting my butter as quick as possible,
I want the maximum amount of time
to decorate my pie.
[Steven] It is quite a challenge, you have
to come up with all this decoration,
and then on top of that,
you've got to have good pastry.
I didn't do it to time
last time I practised it.
[Paul] They've got to make
four individual savoury pies,
but they must be connected
in some way through the decoration.
It's all about that little bit of work
with the knife
and the egg wash to create something
that looks amazing.
Intricate pastry work
takes a lot of skill,
and there's a temptation to keep
fiddling around
with these tiny little bits of pastry,
and of course the more you fiddle,
the tougher it gets
and it loses its crumbly deliciousness.
[Paul] The pies might look amazing
but when you put that fork in
and put it in your mouth,
it's got to flake,
it's got to taste buttery,
and then you look forward to that filling.
They've got to think of not just
the outside, but also the filling too.
-[Paul] Hello, Yan.
-Hello.
So what have you decided
to do for the savoury pie challenge?
The theme of my pie is science,
and it's based on
British scientists.
-Okay. Er...
-The nerd pie.
-No, it's fine.
-This is a nerd pie.
Geek pie.
[Sandi] Steven Hawking, Charles Darwin,
Alan Turing, and Franklin and Crick
will all be honoured
with their own chicken curry pie.
[Yan] For the Turing pie,
I'm cutting out binary code,
ones and zeros sealing the pie.
-Ah!
-Around the, um, DNA helix...
I'm plaiting so it looks like a DNA helix,
and then, and then pushing it down.
That decoration alone would take me a day.
Almost more difficult
than splitting the atom.
[Sandi] Complicated
or beautifully simple...
Done, 400.
Every themed signature pie
will require a perfect shortcrust pastry.
[Steven] Shortcrust is three ingredients,
plain flour, butter, lard.
If you put them together correctly,
you end up with just beautiful pastry.
Don't tell it I'm frightened of it.
[Liam] I've enriched it by two eggs
with a couple of
tablespoons of water as well.
I've got baking powder in my pastry,
puffs up a bit in the oven, which I like.
Get this into a bit of a ball.
You do have to be a bit light-handed.
[Yan] If you play with it too much,
it'll work the gluten and become tough.
It's a fine balance.
[Noel] Steven is attempting to perfect
not one shortcrust pastry...
[Steven] Oops. Get it in the bowl, Steven.
...but two.
[Steven] I've got two batches
of plain shortcrust in there
and this is going to be more
for the decorating
on top with an egg yolk.
[Noel] His second enriched shortcrust
will decorate pies
filled with Swedish meatballs,
mashed potatoes and lingonberry jam,
and all four will join together
in musical harmony.
[Steven] I'm representing songs
from my favourite band.
-Now...
-Which is?
Well, if I tell you the songs,
do you think you could guess it?
Okay, go.
-"Big Love."
-Oh...
-"Storms."
-"Songbird."
-Yeah.
And "Angel."
-Uh, Fleetwood Mac.
-There you go, obviously a fan yourself.
So, what is it you like
so much about them?
Childhood memories. Again my mother
cooking and listening to Fleetwood Mac.
[Sandi] For one baker,
music is just the beginning.
John Lennon is going
on the pie and Einstein.
-Well, that's Shakespeare, isn't it?
-[Prue] William Shakespeare.
And Amelia Earhart as well.
Portraits of people
who I personally find inspirational.
[Sandi] Kate's personal fab four
will be immortalised atop pies
crammed with a delicious medley
of garden vegetables and fresh herbs.
They look quite intricate.
They are quite, erm,
what I've done, I've just,
for ease of cutting them out today,
I've made sort of like rough moulds
and then I'll emboss them.
I've got little tools I use and they,
they keep the shape quite well
in the oven as well.
-It's amazing.
-Thank you.
-Fantastic.
-I'm excited to see a pastry Lennon.
-[laughs] Me too.
-It's going to be great.
Pastry done.
Now I'm going to make the filling.
[Liam] Burn the sausages first.
-R squared plus R squared.
-I'm not sure what you are doing,
but I think the recipe's
a bit complicated.
It's to do with filling versus pastry.
It's the equation for the perfect pie.
-Is it?
-It is.
-I love that there is such a thing.
-Seriously.
-There is, but this is--
-That's made me really happy.
[laughs]
[Noel] Stacey's approach
to filling her pie...
[Stacey] There's quite a lot
of onion in here.
...is a little more homely.
Quite simple, onions,
mincemeat, pine kernels.
This reminds me of the kind of food
my Grandma Elsie used to cook.
Now, I'd love to speak to my grandma,
she'd be so proud I'm on this,
she used to watch it all the time
and I'd love to speak to her, but alas.
[Sandi] Grandma Elsie, along with
the rest of Stacey's family,
have also inspired her signature
bake's theme.
My theme, love.
You're going to bring love back in.
-Yes.
-I can see red
and paintbrushes, I'm getting excited.
I thought, "Ooh, I wonder what'd happen
if I put a little bit of colourin'
in my egg wash?"
You had such a good week last week,
didn't you?
Yeah, and I hope
I can continue it into this week.
I love the idea of the flavours.
-I think it really works.
-Well, we'll see.
[Noel] Whilst Paul and Prue
will expect incredible flavours...
[Yan] I would marinade the meat overnight,
but I don't have that luxury here,
so I am going to use a vacuum sealer
so the meat will suck in the spices.
...delivering them
can come at a huge cost.
There you go, that's done.
Almost every ingredient
the bakers use in their fillings...
I've got potatoes boiling,
I've got lingonberries cooking down.
...has the potential
to release shortcrust pastry's nemesis.
I'm towelling off my spinach.
Moisture.
I just want the vegetable and butter bean
to be a bit more reduced than this,
so not too saucy.
[Sandi] While most are cooking
off their fillings...
[Liam] Right, cook.
...hoping to ensure
their pastry stays dry...
Got to get the meatballs done.
If you like that sort of thing.
One baker is risking the raw approach.
I've chosen this filling because
that's what I normally make for my family,
they just love it, so I thought, why not?
[Sandi] Julia's hoping her sausage meat
and stuffing will cook through
as her pastry is baking.
How have you obtained this colour?
What have you got in there?
Smoked paprika.
[Prue] So, what's the theme?
I'm making things
that you can find on a tree.
So, one's going to be
fully covered with leaves...
-Okay.
-...another one's got an acorn,
and the third one's going to have,
like, a flower,
and the fourth one's going to have grapes.
Grapes on a tree?
You can find it on my tree.
[Noel] The only thing
I'm disappointed about
is you're doing stuff
you can find in trees,
and you're not doing a monkey.
Sorry to disappoint you.
I mean, or a sloth.
-That's going to--
-[Prue] Or a small boy. Yep?
Or Noel.
Or Noel, yeah.
I do live in a hollowed-out tree.
I'm going to get out of here,
it's getting really weird.
-Okay, see you later.
-Thank you very much indeed.
Thank you.
[Sandi] Even if they've managed to reduce
the moisture in their fillings...
Everything's going to plan so far.
...a shortcrust pie is still vulnerable.
I'm just lining my tins with the pastry.
If the rested pastry is rolled too thick,
there may not be enough remaining time
to bake it correctly.
[Liam] Stacey, how long do we have left?
-One hour eighteen.
-Cool.
I'm doing my pastry quite thin
to avoid it going soggy.
[Liam] The right thickness.
[Sandi] To achieve optimum crispness,
Yan has a scientific solution.
I'm sealing it with egg
so that the moisture stays in the pie
-so that it doesn't leak.
-[whistling]
But one baker's
being even more cautious than Yan.
I'm just blind baking it with a bit of egg
to firm up the bottom.
[Sandi] Sophie will fill her
blind baked pies
with roasted squash,
blue cheese, and spinach.
And they'll be decorated
to represent the four seasons.
[Sophie] I've just had to do what I can,
like, every step.
I've kind of been fighting
moisture problems, erm, the whole time.
[Sandi] Bakers, you have one hour left
before your clever combining of flour,
water and shortening
needs to taste better than that sounds.
I really need to get this show
on the road here.
[Noel] Creating elaborate decorations
in shortcrust
is as fiddly as pastry work gets.
[Sophie] I always give myself
difficult things to do,
and the thing is, like,
once I've decided on an idea,
I can't bring myself to simplify it.
[Noel] And with four separate designs
to perfect...
Alan Turing, let's go.
...the more time spent
cutting and shaping...
Seventeen.
...the less time there'll be
to bake the pie itself.
[Steven] If it was four designs
all of the same,
probably wouldn't be so much
of a problem but it's not.
I need to stick to my timings,
and if I don't, then obviously
I won't get it done. Yeah.
[Noel] Liam's carefully
scheduled decorations
for his sweet potato,
feta and chorizo pies
have been inspired
by the second love of his life.
When I don't bake, I play a lot of,
erm, football, video games...
Right.
So one of my patterns
is like a remote control.
-[laughter]
-Okay.
And then I've got the football kits.
Er, and what's your team?
Man United.
It's such a shame
you have to leave this week.
[laughter]
If I do go, you know why.
[Sophie] My pastry cases worked well.
Next one. DNA ladder.
I've just eaten a bit of your pastry.
You didn't need that
little tiny bit did you?
No, no, no, it was raw though. Did you...
-I like raw pastry.
-Oh, do you, really, seriously?
It's a Danish thing?
-No, I think it's just me.
-You? Okay.
It's going to be Einstein in a minute,
when I put his facial features on there.
This is "Songbird." I did need to show
some sort of pastry skills
other than cutting things out.
[Yan] Darwin. Origin of Species.
Really running out of time here.
[Sandi] Just forty-five minutes remaining.
It's just all really fiddly.
[Kate] I'm actually now
running out of time.
I just want to get the filling inside.
Big spoon anywhere?
-What you looking for?
-This.
[panting] Quick! Oh,
it's like Supermarket Sweep.
Pants.
[Steven] Fill those, put the tops on,
then get the decorations on.
-You going to be on time?
-We might actually make this.
[Liam] Twenty-nine minutes?
-[Stacey] Thirty-three.
-Oh, okay, cool.
It's not really cool.
[Yan] I'm straining juice
because my filling is a little bit wet.
[Steven] Normally you would serve
lingonberry jam on the side,
but I wanted to get this into a pie,
so I mixed it in with the mash and it,
well, it makes a sort of
an interesting colour as well, I suppose.
[Julia] Would you like some raw meat?
-No, I'm all right, cheers.
-I can fry it up for you? No.
-I'm not a wolf. I don't eat--
-I can fry it up for you.
Just eating raw meat
out of the back of the tent.
Ugh!
Shakespeare.
Okay. Space pie. Home straight.
-It's getting a bit fiddly now.
-This is gonna be on top of "Big Love."
[Julia] Nice and careful.
It's probably not as neat
as I wanted it to be,
but who really knows
what William Shakespeare looks like?
It will be fine, I'll be fine.
[Sophie] Doing the basket weave
straight on the pie,
it misshapes so much in the moving of it
that actually it just made more sense
just to do it straight on the pie.
Whoa!
[tense music playing]
Mmm, torn my code.
I'm running out of time.
Right, bakers, thirty minutes left.
You all right, Noel?
Sorry, I just glazed over.
Bored?
No, no, covered in egg white, Prue did it.
They should be in already.
A little glaze, a little shine, ugh.
[Sophie] So, I've got a milk wash,
a normal egg wash,
and I'm going to use an egg yolk,
and it just gives it different depths
of browns.
[Julia] I've put it in a really hot oven,
240 degrees,
just to make sure
that everything is cooked through.
[Liam] Time to go in the oven.
[Noel] Unless all the pies are ready
to go in the oven at the same time...
-I'm going.
-...the bakers may not be able to achieve
-an even bake across all four.
-[sighs]
See you, babies.
Just gonna put that one in.
Start that bad boy off.
Putting one in.
[Steven] I wasn't going to stagger them,
I wanted to get them all in at once.
I want that pastry to be cooked.
I want to have at least one cooked.
[Sophie] I've still got
one more to work on.
Planet, come on, planet.
In she goes.
What's everyone else doing?
Sophie's not got hers on yet.
Pow, science pie.
[sighs] I hate rushing,
I hate rushing, it's not me.
I've got all of them in the oven
apart from this one.
Oh, I've just ruined John Lennon's eyes.
Looks a bit more like Noel Gallagher,
'cause I'm in a rush.
That is gonna go in
for as long as I've got,
and then I'm going
to get them out right at the last minute.
I don't want John to look a bit,
you know, anaemic.
They might all be anaemic.
Bakers, you have five minutes left
to finish your feast for four.
Mine are going to be actually raw.
[Steven] What have you got it on?
-Two hundred.
-Whack up the temperature.
[Stacey] I've turned it up to 200
instead of 190,
which is what I do it at home.
[Steven] Maybe I should've
compromised on the design
and allowed them to cook for a bit longer.
It's definitely pie.
[Kate] It's a raw pie.
Cook, you rotters.
[Julia] It is browning up a bit too much,
so, I'll put a bit of foil,
hopefully it will work.
Bakers, you've got one minute left.
Desperate Dan
is on his way to sample your pies.
He's getting a lift
with his brother Desperate Ian.
Could you let me know
when there's 30 seconds left?
They've collapsed a bit,
the designs aren't as I had described.
Okay, cool, time to take out.
Do not fall.
[Sandi] Right, bakers,
that is your pie pit stop.
Please place your pies
at the end of your benches.
[Steven] One raw pie.
-[Yan] Me too.
-Awesome, dude.
-There's one.
-That's totally rad.
[both laugh]
-[Kate] I am so embarrassed.
-Why, it looks...
[Kate] They're raw and messy.
Shakespeare, Einstein, who is that?
[Kate] Please don't.
Shall we just... Just don't.
[laughs]
[Sandi] Now, for the first time
in this year's competition
the bakers will have their pastry
judged by Paul and Prue.
-Hi, Sophie.
-Hi, Prue.
Hello, Sophie,
tell us all about your savoury pies.
So I have the four seasons
and the filling
is a roasted butternut squash,
spinach, and blue cheese.
I love this plaiting around the outside.
That is so neat.
So why didn't you leave it in there
a little bit longer
to get that latticework cooked
a little bit more?
Oh, no, that was intentional,
so that's got a milk wash on it.
-Yeah.
-[Paul] And this one?
Oh, maybe that could have done
with a bit longer. [chuckles]
[Prue] Gosh, that looks good.
[Paul] That pastry,
it's crispy all the way through.
I think blind baking
was a definitely a good choice.
I think it helped.
[Prue] And that filling looks perfect.
[Prue] You've got enough sauce in there
to stick it together,
-but not so that it sogs up the pastry.
-Yep.
A little bit of saltiness
coming from the blue cheese.
Blue cheese is such a great flavour,
but it hasn't killed the butternut,
it hasn't killed the spinach.
You've got a really good balance.
[Paul] The whole thing together
is absolutely delicious.
Really good.
You've got the right sauce level as well.
-[Prue] That is a triumph.
-Well, thank you very much.
-That's a proper Prue pat you got there.
-Yeah, no, a Prue pat.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-I'll just double check for them as well.
-Yeah.
-Just take that with me.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-Thank you.
Nice decoration, and actually
the colours are all fairly even
except for this one. What happened?
Yeah. That was the last one in the oven,
it was just a rush at the very end.
[Prue] Beautifully made.
I think the little hearts around
the edge are absolutely beautifully done.
[Paul] Okay.
-[Steven] Item one.
-[Paul] Nice bake all the way down.
[Prue] Perfect.
That is very good pastry.
I have to say it
doesn't look really pretty.
I mean, there's something
quite upsetting about eating pink mash.
The colour's unfortunate.
It looks a bit like raw pork.
[Prue] But the flavour's good.
The berries with the mash
are the star of the show.
[exhales deeply]
[Paul] Nice bold colour.
[Prue] Yeah.
[Paul] I think you could have done
with a little bit less.
-Okay.
-If I'm honest.
Was it yours that has the, uh,
baking powder in it?
You see, I honestly think that's a mistake
'cause it's made it a tiny bit cakey.
Can't really taste the sausage, mate,
it's just paprika,
that's all you're getting,
really coming through it.
Not your best work,
a little bit disappointed.
Sorry.
I don't think they look good.
-No.
-I think the plaiting is okay,
but you've lost
all the definition on it as well.
-Let's go for... Is that Jesus Christ?
-[Prue] Don't rise to the bait, Kate.
Oh, I won't, no.
It's a bit boring.
I mean, it's perfectly pleasant,
but you don't think, "Oh, that's divine."
And you do have a couple of soggy bottoms.
I've seen you bake
a lot better than this, Kate.
[sighs]
[Prue] The expectations
are tremendously high,
and really it does look a bit of a mess,
and they don't all look
quite evenly baked.
I was struggling for time, so I thought
I'm gonna get at least one pie cooked
'cause I don't want to give you
anything raw to eat.
I think the one we are safest with
is trying this one here, with the colour.
-It's baked at the bottom.
-Ooh!
Your pastry is delicious,
buttery, flaky, I don't think
it's the same on the others.
No.
The chicken is tremendously dry
and over-cooked. The pastry is perfect.
It is pastry week,
just remember that, when you...
Yeah, but, and filling
as well, unfortunately.
And decoration.
And four the same.
-Oh, bum.
-[Paul] But besides that...
-Sorry, am I...
-Thank you.
-Am I allowed to say "bum"?
-Yeah, 'course.
Overall actually, I quite like
the colour of the pies,
one thing I do like is the dome.
I love that classic dome.
Let's have a quick look at this one.
Oh, it is baked.
Okay.
[Prue] Ooh, that looks good.
Very flaky, looks a great filling.
[Prue] Oh, that looks wonderful.
Look at those colours.
That pastry is terrific,
and it's well-seasoned.
[Paul] I think your textures between the
chorizo and the sweet potato is very good,
very buttery, flaky pastry,
and it is baked.
I think it's a bit of a triumph.
-[Liam] Thank you.
-Well done, Liam.
-[Prue] Keep me a bit for lunch.
-100 per cent.
[Paul] Very clever, very neat.
Like the colour, like your designs,
looks very, very good indeed.
Well baked.
[Prue] It's cooked underneath.
Pastry looks good.
I mean, really well filled.
A mouthful of pastry
and mince is quite gluey in the mouth,
but the flavour's lovely.
Mince can often give out
a lot of moisture,
and actually you've combatted
that quite nicely
'cause it's got
a lovely colour underneath.
And I love that.
That's a nice pie there,
that's very clever.
He's just eating it now, he's just eating.
-Good, it's fine, yeah.
-Reminds me of, reminds me of me nan.
It's like a proper northern pie.
Very well done.
-Thank you.
[Stacey] The pies were actually baked
and that was a result.
How that happened,
someone was obviously looking down on me,
sorted me right out.
Decent, decent.
I found thirty minutes from somewhere.
I have no idea how I did manage that
because I was thirty minutes over
in, in practice,
so, shows what I can do when
I actually pay attention to something.
I've never ever been called
"boring" before, so that's a first.
Ugh, the pie was so good at home,
now people'll think that I don't...
That I can't make pie.
I can. I can so make pie.
[Noel] The bakers' next challenge
is a mystery wrapped in pastry.
Right, bakers, I have to tell you that
your Technical Challenge
has been set for you by Paul.
Paul, have you got any advice
before you leave the tent?
Read it carefully before you start.
Go now, never darken our tea towels again,
until judging, obviously.
For your Technical Challenge,
Paul would like you to tackle
rough puff pastry...
-Of course.
-...and make for us Pastis de Nata.
Basically, Portuguese tarts.
You need to make 12 of the beauties
with a crispy, firm base
and a perfectly set, smooth custard.
[Sandi] You've got two hours
to make your Portuguese tarts.
[both] On your marks, get set, bake.
[Noel] The bakers
all have identical ingredients
and Paul's pared down recipe.
[Julia] If I make custard tarts,
I've always done it with shortcrust.
I never done it with rough puff.
Have I had a Portuguese tart?
Of course, I have.
I know the pastry, it's like a spiral.
Yan, how d'you say it, babe?
-Pastis de Nata.
-[Steven] Pastis de Nata.
[imitating Steven]
Pastiche de Nata.
Egg tart, love.
So, Paul, why have you set
Pastis de Nata as a Technical Challenge?
It's one of my favourite bakes
of all time.
-[Prue] Where do things go wrong?
-From the very beginning.
They've got to understand the philosophy
of how a rough puff pastry actually works.
You're producing a flat dough with butter
in and on and folding it and chilling it
and folding it again,
which pushes the layers apart
which creates this beautiful flaky pastry.
Moving on to the filling,
nata meaning cream.
So, although, it hasn't got cream in,
the texture is very much like cream,
silky and smooth.
[Prue] Can we eat one?
[Paul] You certainly can.
But look at the base.
You have that characteristic
swirl around the bottom
but when you bite into them...
[Prue] Go on then.
Crisp pastry on the outside,
slightly chewy in the middle.
Mmm-hmm.
-It's really heaven.
-Now, they are worth the calories.
They are worth the calories.
It says "Make the rough puff pastry dough
using the chilled butter."
I've never made rough puff,
so this will be a challenge.
[Steven] I'm just rubbing
the chilled butter into the flour,
then I am going to add in
drops of ice-cold water.
[Sophie] Everything on this
is supposed to be as cold as possible,
so just trying to keep my hands out
of the equation as much as I can.
Just going to get...
Try and get the right consistency...
Feels a bit dry.
[Steven] Just roll out the pastry
and half the frozen butter
over one turn.
So, that, we are going
to add the other half
and we're gonna bring it back
over like that.
Forgotten how to fold pastry.
So, it's like you fold it,
and then you turn it,
and then you do it again.
I think. [laughs]
Oh, God.
Give it half a turn,
do the same thing again
and that creates the layers
between the pastry and the butter
so it puffs up crispy and flaky.
[sing-songy]
I have no clue if this is right.
And chill.
I'm going to make
a start on the custard now.
"Heat the milk and the flour in the pan,
infusing the cinnamon and pared lemon."
[Sandi] Are you enjoying making it?
[Kate] No, not really.
I've never made rough puff before.
I've never made
this type of custard before.
I don't know what I am doing.
So other than that you have no idea
what you are doing, it's going well?
-Yeah.
-Great.
-It's all under control.
-Okay.
I am going to go and see if I can, uh,
put you on some dating websites.
[laughs]
Seriously, she's got all the qualities
that you are looking for.
She has no idea what she is doing.
I am going to turn my pastry over again.
So, this is after the first chill,
so I am just gonna
roll it out a little bit.
[Noel] Have you ever been to Portugal?
[Julia] No, I've actually never been
to Portugal. Have you?
Quite beautiful-looking people.
I didn't expect it, quite,
quite beautiful-looking people.
All the people there are really beautiful,
I've never felt so ugly in all my life.
Add the sugar syrup to the milk mixture,
so pour that into there.
Combine with the egg yolks.
So much whisking.
[Steven] With custard,
you slowly add hot milk to egg yolks,
and if you don't, you'll curdle the eggs,
so I am just doing it
as slowly as possible.
I have never made
a custard with an actual whisker
so I'm not gonna really start.
It's looking okay. I don't know
if it's going to bake all right.
Roll the pastry dough to a rectangle,
then roll in to a log... How thick a log?
I don't think there's
any hidden messages in there.
I'm just going to go with what I know.
[Liam] Right, so that way.
How many do we have to make, 12?
[sighs] Twelve pieces out of that.
[Steven] I think I see layers.
'Cause it kind of forms
a nice little laminated kind of wheel.
[Liam] I'm very confused.
[Stacey] It doesn't look
a very good disc, does it?
Oh, sugar.
I just realised
that I rolled it the wrong way.
There won't be as much rolls.
You're right.
[sighs]
We've gone the wrong way.
-I've got the same problem.
-Oh, it's so jarring.
[Stacey] That is so annoying.
I just thought it was so obvious
to roll it longways to get it wider, but,
no, it should have been the other way,
the short way and thinner.
Bigger discs, so now
they're not gonna puff up as much.
[Sandi] Now, we should all try and keep up
with the recommended five pastries a day,
but these Portuguese tarts
are born of a different habit altogether.
[Sandi] And it was here
at the magnificent monastery
of Jernimos in Belem outside Lisbon,
that a few religious folks
with frankly time
and egg yolks on their hands
created one of Portugal's
most famous bakes,
the great Pastis de Nata.
I want to find out exactly
how we got from monks and nuns to tarts.
In Portugal at the time, there were
an awful lot of monasteries and convents.
and you had a lot of priests
and a lot of nuns, and they had wimples
-and vestments.
-White clothes.
There's always white stuff,
and it needs starching,
and in those days they used egg whites.
So, a lot of egg yolks left over.
What are you going to do with them?
Using those spare egg yolks,
the monks of Jernimos
created their iconic custard tart,
and 180 years later,
they are still being made
to the same recipe.
Can you show me how to do it?
[Miguel Clarinha]
Just go for constant round movement,
always the same direction,
and don't worry about
pressing it on the top.
[Sandi] Spreading the layers
evenly up the side of the tin
is key to creating
the perfect flaky pastry case.
-So I'm gonna push, turn.
-[woman] No, no, no.
[Sandi] No, other way. [chuckles]
-It's hard.
Takes a lot of practice.
They are famous all over the world,
what do you think it is about them?
[Miguel] Being able to keep
the original recipe
and the dough
is actually a little bit salty,
I think it's this contrast
between being sweet
and salty that makes it
so special and so different.
It looks like the simplest movement,
but it's a piece of art to make it.
-Is it getting better?
-[woman] It's better.
-[laughs]
-There you go.
[Noel] Bakers, you have one hour left.
I've got a little
Portuguese fact for you,
"Portuguese footballer, Cristiano Ronaldo,
once fired a custard tart out of a bazooka
-stunning a chaffinch in flight."
-[laughter]
So, bear that in mind
as you are making your tarts.
It says "Place each disc
into a muffin tin."
"With your fingers,
line the bottom and the sides."
[Sandi] If the bakers
over-handle their rough puff...
they'll crush the delicate layers
they worked so hard
to build up in the pastry.
[sighs]
I am not really happy right now
because it just ripped.
Oh, God.
They are big tins and not much pastry,
so I'll make it stretch a bit.
That's not right.
If I had a smaller tin
I would be all right.
[Yan] Oh, yeah, baby.
I don't know whether
it's supposed to be like that or not.
They look all right, don't they?
I think, yeah, I'd like them a bit neater.
They look quite different
than some of the other bakers.
-Really?
-Some people have got smaller cases.
-Well, I don't know who is doing it right.
-Who knows?
I don't know whether
I should make them wider or just do it.
[Julia] My pastry is absolutely rank.
Okay, so I am filling my tarts now.
[Noel] Custard consistency is key.
Too thick now, and when it bakes,
it will never achieve the silky-smooth
texture of a Pastis de Nata.
I've done my custard,
it's definitely right.
[Julia] It's so foamy. I whisked
the eggs obviously too much.
-Do not drop this, Steven.
-I am going in.
[Sophie] I'll put them on for 18 minutes.
Twelve minutes. I think.
I think they should be kind of set on top,
and like brown I think.
Start it off with 10
and then check it all the time.
Still wet.
[Liam] They are a bit puffy at the side,
I don't know
what they are meant to look like.
[Julia] Two of them look fully covered,
but now they have kind of sunk.
Okay, an absolute disaster.
They need to be spread out.
[heavy thud]
I'm having a bit of a problem.
Right, bakers, five minutes before
you must present your Pastis de Nata.
[Steven] They're not ready yet.
[Kate] No.
[Noel] Are these done?
Yeah, well, sort of, I need,
just need to put some colour on them.
Okay, how do you do that
with a little shh?
-Little, um, flame-thrower?
-I'm not sure.
-Bunsen burner?
-I don't think so.
-I'm just going to put it under the grill.
-Oh, okay.
I wish they were browner on top.
[Stacey] They're a bit burnt.
They don't look too happy, do they,
my pathetic little Natas?
They are meant to be browned
a little bit on top,
you know, like burnt spots?
[Julia] I think they have got
dark patches on them.
Pastry is quite crisp.
I really don't know
whether the pastry is done.
[Sophie] Yeah, there's
really good lamination on it,
which is awesome.
You have one minute
to finish your tarts off.
Do you know, in another context
that might really sound weird.
I'm playing chicken.
I think it's turned to scrambled egg.
God.
I'm not sure how they're supposed to...
I just don't know.
They look like the real thing,
let's hope they taste like the real thing.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please bring your
Pastis de Nata up to the table.
[Kate] Mine look so burnt.
[Noel] Paul and Prue will be looking
for perfectly crisp puff pastry cases
with a swirl on the bottom
filled with smooth, creamy,
lightly mottled custard.
Shall we get started
then on this one then, Prue?
[Prue] They are about the right colour.
[Paul] So this has got a swirl,
it looks quite well baked as well.
Custard is a little solider
than I'd expect.
Yeah, it's not as light as it could be,
but it is creamy,
and actually the shells are okay.
Moving on to number two.
What we have there are chocolate cupcakes.
[Prue] With a swirl, sort of.
[Paul] The pastry case isn't too bad,
but that top, you can taste
the burntness coming from it.
Number three,
this is a bit irregular actually.
The colouring there is not too bad.
My issue is, there has been
no lamination on that.
There is no swirl
there either, underneath.
Huge amounts of issues here.
That's half the depth it should be.
There is a swirl. Where has all the rest
of the custard gone?
It doesn't look like
a Pastis de Nata at all, does it?
The flavour is surprisingly okay.
[chuckles]
These shells look much better.
We have the
characteristic swirl underneath.
[Prue] That's good.
They are a little bit better,
but the custard is quite solid.
I've got great hopes
for this one because it looks good.
[Paul] There is a swirl,
the overall feel is good.
That custard looks to me perfect,
it's creamy, it's got the blotches on it.
They are pretty good, the pastry is good,
the custard is particularly good.
[Prue] Right. Last one.
This looks more like
shortcrust than flaky.
You can hardly see
the swirl at all, very tough pastry.
-Ugh.
-[Prue] Not good.
[Sandi] So, who has achieved
Portuguese Pastis de Nata perfection?
In seventh spot is this one,
whose is this?
Julia, it's like shortcrust pastry.
In sixth place,
this one here, no-one owning up?
[laughter]
Stacey.
-Don't ask.
-This is not your finest hour.
[Sandi] Kate is fifth,
Liam fourth
and Steven is third.
In second place, we have this one...
Sophie, the swirl is perfect,
the pastry is properly cooked,
it's not a bad Pastis de Nata.
That leaves number one.
-[applause]
-Thank you.
Custard was excellent.
You managed to get
the beautiful mottle on the top
and the whole thing tasted very nice.
I'm totally relieved,
that takes a little bit of the edge off,
and now I know that my pie is...
My pie is good.
Not top three, not bottom three.
The plan was to
go kind of higher every week,
and I seem to do this all the time,
so I kind of need to be more consistent,
kind of grow a bit more.
All to play for tomorrow I guess.
[quacking]
[Sandi] One pastry challenge remains,
one more chance for the bakers
to earn their place in the tent next week.
Who do you think
is in line for Star Baker?
[Prue] I think Liam,
his pie filling was delicious.
[Paul] I think Sophie has done well,
and the butternut squash
and the blue cheese
together was delicious,
and the pastry was gorgeous.
So going in to the showstopper,
who's got to pull out all the stops?
Well, definitely Julia.
[Paul] Julia was last in technical.
She struggled with her savoury pie.
She has not had a good week,
so she has got to do something amazing
to save herself.
-Who else is in trouble?
-I'd say Kate.
Kate actually has been struggling
the last few weeks.
She is just limping through week to week.
I'm actually going to throw
Stacey in the mix as well.
Although I did love her savoury pie,
to come sixth on technical will always
put you into a bit of trouble.
If you have a terrible showstopper,
you are in trouble.
Morning, bakers,
welcome to your final pastry challenge.
So, for your showstopper today,
Prue and Paul would like you to make
a hand-raised pie
with a hot water crust pastry case.
Hot water crust
involves water and it's a bit crusty.
-Got no idea, have you?
-No.
[Sandi] The filling is entirely up to you,
but we want one family-sized pie
that can be shared later on, you know,
by four greedy people.
You have four hours
to make your hand-raised pie.
On your marks...
-Get set...
-Bake.
[timer beeps]
Right.
[Noel] The bakers must start
by making a hot water crust pastry.
So I'm just melting
my lard with some water.
The high fat content in this dough means
that it should be able to hold its shape
in the oven without a mould.
There's something
impressive, isn't there?
About hand-raised pie?
You go... Yeah, I hand-raised it.
Like, you brought it up or something.
Paid for its tuition.
They've got to make
a family-sized hand-raised pie.
It has to be savoury.
They could choose a vegetarian option,
they could choose a meat option,
but we want it topped with glazed fruit,
and it must complement the filling inside.
[Prue] What I am looking for
is really good powerful flavours
and when you cut a slice of the pie
the whole thing must hold together,
like a slice of cake.
The traditional hand-raised pie
uses, essentially, a dolly or a mould
which you shape
your hot water crust pastry round
to create the overall shape of the pie.
Aw, it's the lard,
it stinks like hell. [chuckles]
I've just got flour
and butter in here and then lard.
The idea is that
it's sort of more watertight
so it can keep in juices
without sort of getting too soggy.
[Noel] Sophie's watertight pie crust
will be topped with forest fruits
and filled with venison,
rabbit, wild boar,
and guinea fowl.
One of the big things with a game pie
is when you cut them,
the amount of liquid that comes out
of the bottom of it is horrendous.
-[Sophie] Yep.
-How are you combating that?
I have a little syringe,
so at least if I check the juice,
then it's moist without it...
-Yeah.
-Flooding out.
Hand-raised pies, the concept is simple.
But it's got to, not look like
it was made in a factory,
but you know you... You just...
You can't serve up a wonky pie.
[Sandi] Steven's pie will be
full of the flavours
of a Christmas dinner
and for a touch of festive bling,
he will be topping it with glazed,
glittery cranberries.
I was going to try and be smart
and put a mini Santa in it or something
but I thought no... No, Steven,
curb your design this week,
this is all about the pastry.
[Sandi] Most of the bakers are sticking
to the traditional hot water crust recipe.
Look at that.
But Liam and Kate are spicing things up.
I am making turmeric pastry.
I don't know if it will be that great,
but it should be all right.
[Kate] I'm doing
a turmeric hot water crust,
and inside I am doing
a potato and onion curry.
Floats my boat.
[Sandi] Topped with mango and chilli,
Kate's simple potato curry pie
will be encased in a thin crisp pastry.
Now, the hot water crust pastry
you are using this as your mould?
This, yep.
That's a very big mould.
Have you got enough pastry?
Yes, 'cause I don't like
really, really thick pastry anyway,
so I'm going to roll it relatively thin.
I'm looking forward to this,
specially with the, uh,
mango and chilli on the top as well.
I am only worried about whether
that pastry will be a bit too thin.
So, I'm going to start raising my pie.
I'm going to shake
the pastry around upside-down,
kind of roll it out at the top,
bring it around the sides to the bottom.
[Noel] Because the pies must bake
without their moulds,
ensuring the walls
have an even thickness is crucial.
If they are too thin at the base,
that's where it will collapse.
[Noel] Hand-raised pies have been made
this way for hundreds of years,
but 19-year-old Liam
is doing it his own way.
I am using a cake tin.
I originally, like, formed it around it,
but it didn't work for me.
-So, you are binding the inside?
-Mmm-hmm.
What is your problem, Hollywood?
What is it?
Traditionally, it is on the outside,
not the inside.
[chuckles]
Ignore his face, Liam,
Don't... Look away,
look away from his face.
[Noel] Liam's take on a hand-raised pie
is also a tribute
to his nan's Sunday dinners.
He will fill his pie crust
with curried goat
and top it with a mango
and avocado salsa.
So, do I take the risk
of doing it the traditional way
to make boss man happy,
or do I stick to my guns...
and do what I have done at home? Hmm...
-[Noel] But Liam's not the only baker...
-Right.
...whose crust could land them
in hot water.
[Yan] So, I've read in books,
hand-raised pies,
and they mould it on the inside,
so I didn't know what to believe.
So, I chose the easiest option, as you do.
-Liam.
-String.
I'm doing it exactly
the same way as you have done it.
-I've no idea what to do.
-Outside.
[Julia] I've never actually
tried doing it that way.
-Never.
-[Stacey] Just change it.
-I never tried it.
-[Stacey] Oh!
[Julia] Never.
I think I want to do it,
so I'm giving myself a challenge.
If it works, it'll work.
I'm just going to go and do it.
I'm not going to change it because...
What's the point?
[Yan] Shall we do it?
[Sandi] Are you tempted to re-do it?
[Yan] Yeah, 'cause...
[Sandi] Mmm.
...they might mark me down,
otherwise, but I...
What I don't want is to serve a raw pie.
-Right.
-So, I'm going to go with this one.
And serve it and take the hit.
[Noel] Yan's hoping to distract the judges
with her pie's colourful
chequerboard interior
and her elaborate fruit topping.
I know this one works
because I have done it several times,
fingers crossed.
Now it's all kind of, I think, okay,
just going to bang it
in the freezer for a little bit.
Yeah, it looks all right.
Slam it in the freezer to firm it up.
[Sandi] Whilst the pie crusts chill...
Right, meat time.
...the bakers move on to their fillings.
-Whoa!
-I just lost half my hair.
This is a blue bake sauce,
so a very quick sauce.
So I'm adding blue cheese for the flavour.
When you cut into it,
it kind of holds it all together.
[Noel] Julia's blue cheese sauce
will bind her flavour-packed fillings,
which she will layer into her pie crust
before removing the mould.
[Julia] I feel a bit nervous, obviously,
because I do feel the pressure,
but at the same time I feel good.
I'm just... I will try
and enjoy what I do...
and hopefully it all will go to plan.
I'm making a meat-free pie.
So, it's got a layer of paneer,
and then a layer of curry,
and then a layer of eggs,
Sometimes it's nice just to have
something without meat for a change.
[Noel] Stacey will set off
the flavours of her lentil curry filling
with glazed mango cubes.
-Have you practised this at home?
-I have.
I did two on Friday,
and one was like, bleurgh,
and the other one was standing proud,
so I'm hopefully going to do
a standing proud one today.
[Sandi] One hour of the bake
has already gone...
and whilst Yan and Julia
are filling their pies
before removing them from the mould...
[Yan] Not the most appetising
of looks, so I apologise.
-...the other bakers...
-It's got to come out.
...are about to find out
if they have successfully
hand-raised their pies.
I'm gonna try and take it off the mould
which is the difficult bit.
I don't like this. How do I get this out?
It's got holes in the bottom,
just 'cause if you don't have holes
in the bottom,
it creates a vacuum,
and nothing is coming out.
I'm a crust whisperer,
I will talk that out.
Come on, come on, fella.
Just, oh, away, comes.
Why isn't it coming off?
Are you allowed to do this?
[Steven] Stop me, I dare you.
-There you go.
-Oh, yes. Thank you.
[whispers]
It's happening, come on.
There you go.
What's the baking handshake?
What was it, this one? And then this?
-Yeah.
-Solid.
Me and Paul do that
when you are not looking.
Is it?
Try and keep up with the youth.
[Stacey] Completely cracking.
Hurry up and fill the thing.
[Sophie] I have put some spinach leaves,
and then on the top,
it's the rest of the meats.
I didn't want to layer it too much,
I didn't want it to be too fussy,
but when you cut it open,
it's got to look pretty.
Everyone else is doing
like mad layers and stuff,
and I'm just like,
"Mmm, potato."
[Stacey] I've just realised
something really bad.
There's a bit of
baking parchment in the bottom.
I'm gonna put my lid on and crimp it in.
[Sophie] And I've got to
sort myself out now,
'cause I've got to get this in the oven.
Not good... at all.
[Noel] Bakers, you are halfway through
your hand-raised
pie Showstopper Challenge.
[Sandi] For Julia and Yan,
it's the moment of truth.
[Julia] It doesn't come off.
Don't tell him I did that. [chuckles]
I'm really scared
to take it out of the mould.
-Okay, do you need help?
-Yeah.
[Steven] This wrap that I've put
around the edge is to hold it
just for the first half an hour
whilst that pastry sets.
[Yan] What do you do at home?
[Julia] I use a pallet knife.
-What are you doing?
-I'm trying to patch up a crack.
-Patching up your crack?
-I've got a big crack.
-That's going to leak everywhere.
-Leakage?
-Leaky crack.
-[Noel] So you should...
-Really not a good thing.
-[Noel laughing]
If you take that off, won't it be easier
just to pull it apart or...
Take what off?
This... This is holding
it together, right?
Oh, my God! I can't believe I'm so stupid.
[Kate] Got to get it in the oven.
[Steven] That's probably got to go
on about an hour actually.
There's raw meat in there,
but I don't want
it to be dried out,
that's the problem with turkey.
I've just put it in a bit of foil
'cause I don't want the sort of top of
the meat to burn, 'cause there's no lid,
so just trying to keep
a bit of moisture in.
My aim was to sort of go for a, like, um,
straight on one side
and kind of caved in on the other side
with like a floppy kind of look.
That's my aim. Yeah.
I think they'll buy that.
I am syringing off the juices from the pie
'cause there is a lot of it.
[Steven] Let's get glazing.
I'm making my mango and avocado salsa.
Mango, avocado, pomegranate,
red onions, lime juice, lime zest.
Peaches go with pork,
apricots go with pork,
figs go with pork.
I quite enjoy a bit of fruit.
It makes you feel not so guilty
when you are having
a massive great big fatty pie.
[Sophie] This is for the topping.
Are you okay? You seem fine.
Yeah, fine, you know me,
I'm not a big one with
public displays of emotion. [chuckles]
One day you will crack,
though, you know that.
-Don't cry.
-And burn the tent to the ground.
[mimics Russell Brand]
Bakers, you've got one hour left.
Get your bleeding pies out the oven.
Have you got Russell Brand's
underpants on?
I'm going to take my baking paper off
and hope that
it's gonna hold its shape.
It held. Looks good.
I'm pleased with that.
It's too soggy. God.
[Stacey] It's a disaster...
All... Everything about it.
But maybe they won't notice.
That, that could happen,
that Paul could suddenly, you know,
-turn in to a different person.
-[chuckles] Yes.
Right, get in there.
I want to get somewhere
between 70 and 74.
Go up to 74
'cause there's meat in it.
Sixty-three, got to get up to seventy.
Just wait for it to cook.
Ooh, I don't like this bit.
[Kate] It's cooking nicely.
I reckon it's got
another ten minutes left.
[Steven] It looks done,
but it's the temperature at the top.
It's just infuriating.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes
to finish hand-raising those pies.
I give it another minute for luck.
[Liam] My pie is all right.
It's not too bad.
Pie is cooked.
Yep. It's looking cooked.
Ugh, one side's all right. [chuckles]
Meh...
Just going to give it another ten minutes,
if it's not done, they can't eat it.
I've whacked it up, the lot,
so I've just got to wait.
[Sandi] It looks beautiful.
The top cracked a little bit,
just hope it's going to be fine
because haven't got much time left.
So, what have you got to do next?
[Kate] So, I'm just gonna
cover it with the fruit.
[spraying]
[Steven] It's a shimmer spray and then...
make it rain.
Could not serve them
something without a bit of camp in it.
[Julia] That looks gorgeous.
[Sophie] That's awesome.
Very cool.
[Stacey] I can't put my topping on
'cause it's not flat.
It keeps falling off.
Five minutes.
What minute are you taking--
To the last, almost...
Almost to the last minute.
It's got--
Oh, it's cooked.
You've got one minute left, one minute.
[Steven] I don't want to do it
when it's warm, but...
[Yan] Do you want me to help?
Could you take some of these,
and just like, I'm doing them...
[Yan] Shove them on,
honestly, 'cause then...
[Steven] If you can, yep.
Right, that is the end
of your Showstopper Challenge.
[sighs]
Absolute disaster-looking thing.
[Noel] The bakers
and their hand-raised pies
must now face
the judgment of Paul and Prue.
Did everything go to plan?
-I will know when you cut it open.
-[laughter]
Takes a long time to get
that even smooth outside,
I mean, it is beautifully done.
[Paul] Well done.
Yes.
To do that much game
and not get any liquid out of there
is very, very good.
I think it's an amazing construction,
and I love all the flavours.
[Paul] The forest fruits cut through that,
that tartness really cuts through,
but it's that pastry,
it's too thick on the side,
and so you've got that raw bit of
hot water crust just running through it.
I think it looks great.
[Prue] Oh, look at that,
doesn't that look perfect?
[Paul] The pastry is thin,
but it's held well.
I think the flavour is lovely,
and I think it looks pretty.
I love that.
-Do you?
-Yeah, absolutely.
Coolness of the mango
with the curry just works.
-Very clever.
-Thank you.
It does look a bit of a mess.
[Prue] It certainly looks home-made.
It probably should have been
a bit more professional-looking.
One other thing
I kind of have to tell you.
I'm afraid there's a bit of
baking parchment in the bottom.
Like a surprise. [chuckles]
[Paul] No, it's actually
in the pie, isn't it?
-[Stacey] Yeah.
-[Prue] It is actually in the pie, yeah.
[Stacey] When I took it out of the mould
it was falling apart,
so I filled it up really quickly
and the parchment circle
is still in there.
I'm so sorry.
[Paul] I think if you...
If you were having this as a meal
it would work.
You've made a dish which tastes good
and haven't considered
the hot water crust pastry.
Yep.
[Paul] Look how straight those sides are.
It's neat, it's got a lovely colour on it.
[Prue] It looks really moist
and attractive.
[Paul] It does look good.
You know, overall it's a bit bland.
The stuffing and the turkey
almost taste identical.
The Brussels sprouts
are almost immaterial.
It's a bit of a let down on the flavour.
Now, this one was done
inside the tin, is that right?
Yep.
[Paul] I think it looks all right,
the little bit of crimping
looks quite nice as well.
But I'm dying
to see that chequerboard inside.
Okay.
-[Prue] That does look good. Very nice.
-[Paul] Wow!
It's quite stunning,
the pastry is crispy, it's golden,
nice rich flavour to it as well.
All the sausage meats taste different,
and the fruit works with it.
I think it is absolutely wonderful.
Yes.
-Could have been, uh, much neater.
-[Julia] Yeah.
Where the lid meets the sides,
and they look a bit
sad sitting on the top.
Now, you did this in the tin?
Yeah.
I don't think the asparagus works.
It's all been in the oven too long
because the chicken is dry,
and the asparagus is overcooked.
On the other hand,
the pastry is undercooked.
My conscience kicked in,
so I ended up doing it the traditional way
of using outside the cake tin.
Does your conscience have steely blue eyes
and a silver-grey beard?
[laughter]
[Paul] Right.
[Paul] Well, it's holding together
quite nicely.
But the colours are fantastic,
look at them.
[Paul] Considering
it's a quite lean meat, goat,
that is succulent, it's juicy,
with the plantain
it gives you that lovely smoothness to it
and that tropical flavour as well.
But together, it's really nice,
and when you get that fruit,
that salsa as well,
it's spectacular.
It's absolutely wonderful.
Your grandma is a genius.
Get in. Yes, Nan. [laughs]
-What's your grandma's name?
-Cynthia.
Will she come round
to my house and cook this?
Any time.
Just wanted to make my nan proud,
'cause her food is crazy, like crazy good,
crazy good. Hashtag Cynthia.
[laughs]
[Stacey] Sadly, I haven't felt like
this since week one.
I will be so gutted, I mean,
desperately gutted if I go home.
I'm very pleased with the comments,
I'm really, really pleased.
But, yeah, there's just...
Really worried that...
That's not enough really.
So, we were worried about Julia and Kate,
coming in to the showstopper.
Are we still worried?
[Paul] I thought Kate's looked amazing,
love potato curry,
and for me I think she saved herself.
I thought Julia's was a bit untidy.
The pastry was a bit thick
and raw in places.
And don't forget
she actually did it in the tin.
Which again, does that fit the brief?
I think Stacey is in trouble.
Look at the pie,
the flavours were all over the place.
I think she struggled on pastry week.
So, who is in line for Star Baker?
I think Liam, Yan.
That's a good pastry,
and that's a great filling.
-And Sophie, yeah.
-I think Sophie is still there, Sophie.
The thing about Sophie
was her wonderful fruits
of the forest on the top.
[Paul] It did look good,
looked very professional,
the crimping was great.
Liam just astonishes me week after week.
He is... He's something
of a genius with flavour,
he's got a sort of instinct
for what goes with whatever.
-Can you see Sandi over the pie?
-Oh, shut up.
[laughter]
Bakers,
the person who is Star Baker this week
used the wisdom of their elders
to create a wonderful showstopper.
Star baker is...
Liam.
[applause]
So that leaves me with the horrible job.
Um, you are all amazing,
you are down
to the last seven, it's incredible.
Somebody has to go home,
and it's really painful.
Uh, the person leaving
the tent this week is...
[exhales]
Julia.
I'm so sorry.
Sorry, sweetheart.
[sobbing]
You know you did amazing,
you know that, right?
-Yeah.
-You did incredible.
-Well done, Jules.
-Well done.
-Yeah.
-You did well.
-Thanks.
-You did really well, all right?
'Course I will carry on baking,
that's my passion, that's...
I'm very lucky to find my passion
in something I enjoy doing,
and I absolutely love
when I am only 21.
And you know what?
There is only one place, there is there.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
Hello.
[laughs]
Yeah.
Star baker.
I didn't think I would ever get it.
Just over the moon,
over the moon, um, yeah, just like...
Oh, yeah, I don't...
That's me done,
I can go next week now.
I've got Star Baker.
Mum, I got Star Baker. [chuckles]
[Liam's Mum] Oh, my God.
Why are you crying?
[theme music playing]